well from testing to vaccines to
funerals
it's a dark side of covid but it is
important to talk about
funeral homes are still overwhelmed and
there are fears if more people don't get
vaccinated
it's just going to get worse sasha
loftis joins us tonight from unlv
vaccination site
and sasha this is a pretty uncomfortable
subject but it really is the harsh
reality of cobit for some families
yes denise the families i spoke with
today have seen that darkness
full first hand they encourage you to
really make decisions here at this fact
the vaccination sites like this they say
the decisions you make
can really impact your future and the
future of those around you
she was the funniest lady erica cassell
describes the light
and love of her grandmother marlene she
was a total
glam queen their memories she now
cherishes
after covid19 cut time short last
november
it went from you know pneumonia to
pancreatitis to her kidneys
until it finally just took her it's
excruciating to talk about
but cassal wants others to understand
the trauma
this virus brings when your family
member is dying and you can't hold their
hand
because of the severity of covid you
can't say your final goodbye and your
final goodbye is through a glass door
i mean that will change you
unfortunately marlene's story is
anything but rare the numbers are
increasing we're seeing it every day get
a little worse
funeral director laura sussman says her
team has been
overwhelmed since the pandemic started
and while things got better for a few
months
one third of those she sees now have
died from covid complications
i don't think the general community has
any clue about the
severity of this it's coming back
and it's only going to get worse that's
why erica is urging everyone
to protect themselves and those they
love
from this very same fate when it does
happen to you
it changes you so you really should take
extra precautions
now those running this vaccination site
here tell me that about
70 percent of those that show up are
here for that for covet 19
testing rather well about 20 to 30
percent
are here for vaccinations they say it's
a good place to take advantage of an
opportunity to get vaccinated in an easy
and free
setting to get those vaccination numbers
up here in clark county and across
nevada
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now